اهلا بكم اخيرا نفت قياده القوات المواليه
للوب المتقاعد خليفه حفتر تورط افرادها في
جرائم ب حرب وتعذيب واعدامات ميدانيه
ورفضت طلب مفوضيه الامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان للتحقيق في هذه القضايا لكن هذا
النفي لا يصمد امام ظهور ادله متواليه على
تلك الجرائم احدثها انتشار تسجيل المصور
على موقع فيسبوك القائد العسكري البارز في
قوه حفتر الرائد محمود الورفلي وهو يشرف
شخصيا على اعدام 20 شخصا ملثمين دون ذكر
هويتهم وكانوا يرتدون ملابس كتلك التي
يلبسها تنظيم الدوله لضحاياه وقد ظهر
الورفلي في مقاطع سابقه وهو ينفذ اعدامات
خارج نطاق القانون وطالبت منظمه هيومان
رايتس وتش بالتحقيق في هذه الجرائم
ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنها تقرير لفتح
اسماعيل اختلف الفاعل لكن تطابق
المشهدانى لا يصعب تمييزهما ايهما لتنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه وما هو للرائد محمود
الورفلي القائد العسكري البارز في قوات
اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر اعدام جماعي
خارج القانون لخصوم مقيدي الايدي ومرتدين
ازياء برتقاليه تماما كما يفعل تنظيم
الدوله
بضحاياه وعلى خلاف عناصر التنظيم الملثمين
والمجهولين عاده في ساحه الاعدام يباهي
الورفلي بظهوره مكشوف الوجه وبلباس
العسكري وهو يشرف كما في هذا الفيديو على
اعدام 20 شخصا رميا بالرصاص وفقا لقرار
اصدرته كما قال محكمه ميدانيه شكلها هو
قبل ان يقوم بنفسه باعدام احد الضحايا
المتهمين حسب بيان الورفلي بالضلوع في
اعمال قتل وخطف وتفجير وذبح لافراد من
المؤسسه العسكريه التابعه لحفتر في
بنغازي بمشاهد اعدام مروعه ارتادت شهره
الورفلي افاق فهو اليد الطول لحفتر التي
بها يبطش وبها ينبش قبور الموتى ويمثل
بجثثهم في تسجيل مصور بثته وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في مارس اذار الماضي ظهر محمود
الورفلي وهو يقتل بالرصاص ثلاثه رجال
جاثمين امام جدار وايديهم مقيده خلف
ظهورهم كان الرجال الثلاثه من مقاتلي مجلس
شورى ثوار بنغازي وقد اعدم بلا محاكمه في
الشارع العام بمنطقه بهدمه السكنيه جنوب
غربي بنغازي وكما لا حرمه للحياه في عرف
قوات حفتر فلا حرمه للموت ايضا في عرفها
غدات اقتحامها منطقه قنفوده في بنغازي شهر
اذار مارس الماضي اقدمت تلك القوات وكان
الورفلي احد قادتها على نبش قبور مقاتلي
وقاده مجلس شورى ثوار المدينه والتمثيل
بالجثث كما سحلوا بعضها على سيارات جا
الشوارع قبل ان تعلق الجثث تشفيا على
مشانق في بوابات معسكر قوات
الصاعقه فضاع اهتز لها الشارع الليبي
والمجتمع الحقوقي وعدت جرائم حرب كما
ادانتها الامم المتحده التي طالبت بعزل
الورفلي وامثاله ومقاضاته غير ان شيئا من
ذلك لم يحدث اذ ازداد حفتر تمسكا بجنيه
المخلص وكما لا يعير الورفلي اهتماما
لضحاياه هولا يلتفت الى اي اعتراضات
داخليه او خارجيه بل يمضي قدما فيما يفعل
زاعما ان افعاله تلك تقربه من الله اكثر
متدثرا باراء فقهيه
يشبه ما يحدث في جنوب اليمن ضد شخصيات
ومثقفين في البلدين قوات خارجه على
الشرعيه وفيهما ايضا يهيمن التيار المدخلي
ويتكفل بتوفير الغطاء الفقهي والديني
لعمليات الاعدام والقتل اما الخيط الناظم
بين الساحتين فليس ربما الا الدور
الاماراتي اناقش الموضوع مع ضيفين من
طرابلس محمود اسماعيل
الباحث المختص في الشان الحقوقي والقانوني
ومن اسطنبول نزار كركش الباحث الليبي
ومدير مركز البيان للدراسات السياسيه اهلا
بكما سيد كركش هل لديكم في
البدايه تفهم او فهم بالاحرى لدور الرائد
الورفلي وايضا التيار الديني الذي ينتمي
اليه ضمن منظومه خليفه
حفتر
الصوت غير
واضح الصوت غير واضح سيدي كركش اعود اليك
السؤال ولم استمع للسؤال طيب ساعيد السؤال
هل لديكم فهم او تصور لدور هذا الرجل
الورفلي والتيار الديني الذي ينتمي اليه
ضمن قوات خليفه
حفتر نعم
هو هو الرائد محمد محد الورفلي هناك خمس
كتائب في في في بدينه بنغازي كتيبه
الاسناد القوه الخاصه كتيبه التوحيد
التابعه ل للتيار السلفي وكذلك كتيبه
اولياء الدم هذه
الكتائب السيد محمود الوفاي موجود في
كتيبه القوه الخاصه وهو رائد في هذه
الكتيبه اظن ان ان ان التيار السلفي يعطي
الغطاء الشرعي لكل عمليات الكرامه بمعنى
ان هو يحاول ان يلبس كل ما يقوم به تقوم
به عمليه الكرامه من من فضائع
يجد لها مبررا باعتبار ان من يقاتلهم هم
من الخوارج فبالتالي يظنون هم فيما يظنون
ان الخوارج يمكن ارتكاب كل الفضاء عليهم
فبتالي يصبح الاخر هو الشيطان
وفي تفكيرهم انه يجوز فيه كل فعل كل هذه
الاشياء لذلك وجدنا هذا الشخص يقوم ويتحدث
باسم الدين فبالتالي اظن ان هناك ثلاثه
اذرع لعمليه الكرامه الذراع الاول هي
الذراع الدعم الخارجي المتوفر من من مصر
والامارات الذراع الاعلامي متوفر في عده
قنوات نعرف ان في ليبيا الان حوالي اكثر
من من 30 قناه مسموعه للتيار السلفي وبعض
القنوات الاخرى الموجوده في الاردن
وموجوده في مصر وكلها تدعم عمليه الكرامه
الذراع الثالث وهو ذراع الارهاب ذراع
الخوف الان عمليه الكرامه بعد ان يعني
شارفت على القضاء على خصومه هناك عده تفتك
يعني عده اشكالات داخليه تناقضات داخليه
الان ما يفعله محمود العرفلي او غيره هو
جزء مما تفعله العسكر احيانا ما يعرف
بالشؤون المعنويه اظهار هذه الصوره لهذا
الشخص بهذه الطريقه والتذكير بداعش بمعنى
ان الرساله واضحه اننا يمكن ان نفعل في كل
من يحاول ان يتمرد على هذه القوات الخاصه
او يتمرد على خليفه حفتر ان نحن بامكاننا
ان نقوم بهذه الاشياء الان حفتر في تناقض
بين هذه السياسه ان يسيطر على الوضع
الداخلي لكل اتباعه وبين ان يظهر في في م
مظهر سياسي يمكن ان يخوض السياسه لذلك هو
الان يعيش حاله من التناقض نعم سيد
اسماعيل كما بين التقرير هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يشرف فيها الورفلي شخصيا على
اعدامات ميدانيه دون محاكمات كيف تصفون
هذه الممارسات من الناحيه القانونيه في في
ساحه الوغى مثل ليبيا هل كل شيء مباح
بكل بكل تاكيد لا شك انها اعمال خارجه عن
القانون ينبذها اي عاقل مخالفه لشري الامم
ومخالفه ايضا للنهج السليم ومخالفه ايضا
للعقل سليم لا يمكن ال قبولها بالمطلق هو
مجرم منذ البدء وقان قد ارتكب بدايه
اجرامه منذ ان كان جزءا من كتيبه سميت
بكتيبه نداء ليبيا وجدت ببنغازي من اجل
افشار الثوره الليبيه ثم انضم الى ما
يتعلق بعن جيه حفتر من اجل اعاده ما يتعلق
بالوجه القبيح محاوله قدر الامكان ايضا ما
يجب ان يشار اليه ان هذه اعمال خارجه عن
القانون بالمطلق ويجب ان يكون عليها
محاكمات هي جريمه ضد الانسانيه قتل الناس
مهما كانت صفاتهم اذا كانوا متهمين فليحل
الى المحاكم ولتكون محاكمه محاكمات عادله
ويبح لهم ايضا حق الدفاع عن انفسهم اما ان
يكون هناك خصم وحكم وهناك قتل على هويه
وهناك قتل بدون محاكمه وبدون حقيقه هذا
تشويه للتاريخ لم يكتب الا في زمن الطاغيه
القدافي وها هو يتكرر في زمن طاغيه جديد
وهو حفتر وعصابته هو مسؤول مسؤوليه مباشره
واذا كان حفتر الان في زياره الدوله
الفرنسيه وينتظروا السيد السراج ان يكون
هناك مقابله فاين فرنسا بلد الحريه من
هؤلاء اذا استقبلت مجرمين كهؤلاء نعم
لقتال الارهاب ونعم ان يكون هذا الارهاب
منبوذا من الجميع وبالم طلق لكن ان يكون
هناك ايضا ارهاب فيما يتعلق باستلابي
الناس في قتلهم وعلى الا بدون ان يكون
هناك محاكمه اعتقد انه امر خليط ويجب ان
يشار الى ان مبادئ حقوق الانسان وايضا
تشريع شريعه الامم منبو الامم المتحده في
سنه
1989 سمت نوعا من المستشار الامني الخاص
بما يتعلق بمن يرتكبون جرائم بشعه كما
هؤلاء الذين يرتكبون خارج نطاق القانون
اعمال اباده او قتل ومن المهم جدا العمل
على ان يكون هناك موقف وا ما بد العيان
انه لم يوجد موقف واضح من الدوله الليبيه
ولا من المجتمع الدولي هؤلاء بشر اذا
كانوا مدانين يجب ان يتم محاكمتهم امام
جهات قضائيه اما هذه العاب الاليه ومحاوله
ان يلع بانفس الناس هذا ما لم انه في
ساحات الحرب من الصعب السيطره على الجميع
وهنا اسال السيد كراكش هل من الممكن حصر
ما يحدث الان من انتهاكات ضمن صفوف خليفه
حفتر بانها افعال فرديه لا تمثل قوات حفتر
بشكل
عام لا لا اظن ان هي افعال فرديه لان لان
وجدنا شخص يعني يقوم باعطاء اوامر
وجنود يتحركون حركه نظاميه ويحاولون ان
يعني يعودون يعني المشهد كان معد بعنايه
يذكرنا فعلا بتنظيم الدوله بان هناك
انضباط بين القائد الذي يامر والجندي الذي
يطيع فبالتالي قضيه العمل الفردي هذه يعني
غير وارده ما هو وارد الان هل حفتر فعلا
فقد السيطره على مجموع الكتائب الخمسه
الموجوده التي ذكرتها في السابق ام ان
حفتر الان يحاول ان يرسل رساله لكل من
يخالفه لان الان بنغازي منقسمه بنغازي
الان فيها كما ذكرت مجموعه كتائب وهناك
احتقان يجب ان لا يفهم في اطاره حتى
السياسي هناك جرائم حدثت اثناء ثلاث سنوات
يصعب السيطره عليها حتى من سلطات يعني
رسميه ما بال بمجموعه كتائب ومجموعه
مدنيين لان الخطا الاكبر التذي حدث في
عمليه الكرامه هو اشراك المدنيين في
عمليات مسلحه هذا الاشراك يعطي المدني
الحاله من من السلطه والجاه الذي يصعب
الانفكاك عنها فالسؤال هل فقد حفتر
السيطره على الشرق ام ان هذه رسائل واظن
هذا هو الارجح هي رسائل لكل من يحاول الان
ان يقوم لان هناك بعض القبائل الكبيره جدا
في مدينه بنغازي هي غير راضيه على عمليه
الكرامه ورات بان حفتر اصبح يتحول نحو
السياسه حفتر الان ليس هو الشخص الذي جاء
في عمليه الكرامه ويحث الناس على محاربه
الارهاب وينشر يعني بعض ويستعين ببعض بع
رجال الاعمال ويحاول ان يظهر كمنقذ للوطن
الان حفتر واضح بانه يريد ان يذهب الى
باريس ويريد ان يمارس السياسه فكل من تبعه
اثناء عمليه الكرامه اصبح يتساءل اين انا
من هذا المشهد السياسي يعني بما بما ان
هناك تناقضات داخليه يعرفها وحفتر فلا بد
الان من رسائل هذه الرسائل تقول بان كل من
يحاول ان يخرج عن الطاعه سيحدث له ما حادث
لهؤلاء المساكين العشرين الذين لا نعلم من
هم يعني حتى تحليلنا الان لا نعلم من
هؤلاء بالضبط الاغلب ان يكون هناك جزء من
الارهاب الداخلي لكل القوى ولكل الكتائب
الموجوده في بنغازي حتى يمكن السيطره
عليها وارسال هذه الرساله لها و يتفرق
حفتر لاعاده الصوره الذهنيه للشارع الليبي
عن حفتر كرجل سياسه لان كل
الم من عام 201 2013 انه كان يرغ ال
السياسي اكثر من العمل السع نعم سيد
اسماعيل المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه العليا
لحقوق الانسان طالبت اللواء خليفه حفتر
باقصاء الفر الورفلي ووقف هذه الممارسات
بتقديرك هل هذا ممكن هل هل هو
وارد ما يبعث على القلق ان الامم المتحده
وبعثتها طالبوا بان يكون هناك محاكمه وان
يكون هناك تحقيق وان يكون هناك نتائج لهذا
ما بدا واضحا للعيان انه تقدم في شهر
ابريل بالاستقاله ورفض هذا الطلب ثم رقي
فكان في في بدايه جرائمه التي ارتكبها
نقيبا واصبح يتكلم على انه رائد اي انه قد
منح ترقيه استثنائيه جراء اعماله البشعه
ضد الانسانيه واقع ان هناك حقيقه عدم
انسجام في هذا الموقف هل هل وصلت الامور
الى الاستهزاء بما يتعلق بما ينشر من
تقارير وما يبدا من جرائم واقع ان الامور
اكثر فضاع واكثر بشاعه في في ما يتعلق
بعدم الانتقاد لها هذه جرائم يجب ان يتم
محاكمته ولا تسقط ايضا بالتقادم ما يجب ان
يشار اليه انه يجب ان يتجه من الذي يدعمه
معنويا وماديا ومن الذي يقف وراءه وما هي
الجرائم التي ارتكبت لماذا لم يتم اضاع
حتى اسمائهم او وجوههم ولماذا لم تنشر اذا
ارتكبوا جرائم هناك محاكمات وهناك محاكم
ثم ان حفتر يتبجح بانه قد سيطر وقد نشر
العداله فاين العداله من هؤلاء ام انهم
ليسوا بشرا اتوقع ان تكون الامور اكبر مما
يتصور الجميع بل هم ربما من جزء من
المسجونين وما ادراك ما المسجونون الذين
هم يعانون الامرين في سجون عفتر العنتريه
ثم يذهب الى عاصمه النور باريس من اجل ان
ينشر على انه منقذ ليبيا هو حقيقه وجه بشع
ومحاوله قدر الامكان لارجاع صوره
الدكتاتوريه العسكريه وان اعتقد ان
المثقفين الفرنسيين والساسه الفرنسيون
مدركون لح حقيقه هذا الدكتاتور جرائمه في
تشاد وجرائمه حاليا في ليبيا لا يمكن ان
تمر بهذا المرور ولذلك على ايض السلطات
الليبيه نوعها ان يكون لديها موقف من هذه
الجرا هنا هناك محاولات لتصوير خليفه حفتر
على انه قائد وطني
جامع جيد جيد السؤال سيد
نزار الى اي مدى يمكن لهذه الممارسات ان
تؤثر على ما يحكى بانه مصالحه وطنيه وبان
يستلم جيش الكرامه او جيش خليفه حفتر
السيطره على كامل الاراضي الليبيه الى اي
مدى يؤثر او تؤثر هذه المشاهد بالمواطن
الليبي ن هو هو الراي العام الليبي يعني
يتاثر خاصه بالمشهد الذي يذكر بتنظيم
الدوله يعني الناس تقول نحن تخلصنا من
تنظيم الدوله لنعود لتنظيم الدوله بصوره
اخرى هذا صوره ذهنيه غ سيئه جدا ولكن ما
ما ما الذي يحدث الان يحدث الان ان يصبح
من تبع المجرم او الدكتاتور في لحظه من
اللحظات يصبح عبء على الدكتاتور فبالتالي
يفسح له المجال لارتكاب مجموعه من الفظائع
يرهب بها اعدائه الداخليين ثم هو يظهر في
صوره اخرى في في في في في في مجال اخر
يمارس السياسه ليقول للناس انا اسف لاني
غير قادر على السيطره على هؤلاء فبالتالي
هو يحاول ان يلعب يحاول ان يوازن بين
الصوره الداخليه التي يرهب بها الدا
الداخل ويعلم بان المجتمع الدولي يتغاضى
عن هذه الجرائم اذا كان هناك عمليه سياسيه
توحي بامكانيه الاستقرار لذلك التوقيت
الان مهم جدا لان الان اي يعني اي اشكال
في بنغازي سي سيزعج حفتر تماما ويجعله غير
قادر على الحركه الخارجيه لذلك يجب الان
ان يهدئ الشارع الداخلي في بنغازي خاصه
هذه الكتائب وان يكبح اي محاوله للتمرد
عليه ليتفرغ لاحياء الصوره الذهنيه
الجديده التي يريد
وهي المشاركه في العمليه السياسيه الان ما
يزعجه حقا ما يعكر الامر هو تدخل الجزائر
الجزائر ارسلت رساله واضحه الى خليفه حفتر
بان لن تصمت عن محاولات ادخال اسرائيل او
ادخال ايجاد بعض القواعد المصريه في في في
على الحدود الليبيه الشرقيه لذلك تدخلت
فرنسا بقوتها لتوازن بين الامرين فاذا ما
يحدث الان من فضائح في بنغازي سيحاول حفتر
ان يوظفها سياسيا بان يق بان هؤلاء بعض
الكتائب الغير قادره ان اسيطر عليها لذا
يجب ان اكون هناك جيش رسمي في مدينه طرابس
وبالتالي يصبح الان بين نارين اما ان يكون
واضح سؤال الاخير لمحمود اسماعيل هل من
الممكن ان تؤدي هذه الانتهاكات التي ترتكب
ضمن قوات الكرامه الى ادانه الدول التي
تدعم خليفه حفتر علنا سياسيا و ميدانيا
امنيا باختصار لو
سمحت بكل تاكيد يجب ان متجه الى هذا وما
ادراك ما دعم السيسي والامارات حقيقه
بخافي فيما يتعلق بهذا العنجهيه محاوله
ميلاد دكتاتوريه جديده عسكريه ملها
الليبيون 43 عاما عجافا ثم يخرج عليهم
عفتر يجب ان يتوجه اصابع الاتهام للذين
يساعدونه يدعمونه بطريقه او باخرى هم خارج
نطاق الشرعيه وخارج نطاق القانون لا يمكن
الا ان يقال بان هذه جريمه اباده جماعيه
ضد الانسانيه وعلى الجميع ان ينبذها ويجب
ان تكون هناك محاكمات ومتابعات لهؤلاء
المجرمون ابتداء من محمود الورفلي وايضا
حفتر الذي هو يتزعم هذا الموقف والذي هو
يعتبر مجرم حرب ويجب ان تشار اليه هذا
باصابع واضحه للعيد لا مجال للمغاربه فيها
هو الذين يدعمون واقع عملي ان الليبيون
ملوا من هؤلاء الدكتاتوريون وعليهم ان
ينتجوا ديمقراطيه ناجزه من اجل الجميع
محمود اسماعيل الباحث المختص في الشان
الحقوقي والقانوني في طرابلس وفي اسطنبول
نزار كركش الباحث الليبي مدير مركز البيان
للدراسات السياسيه شكرا لك
في الملف الثالث للحصاد تبحث ازدهار
شعشاعه في الابعاد القانونيه والتداعيات
السياسيه لمحاوله دول الحصار على قطل على
قطر عفوا فرض قيود على حريه التعبير
واغلاق المنابر الاعلاميه وذلك كما يراها
المشاركون في مؤتمر الدوحه لحريه التعبير